you know david blankenhorn was smart
enough to reach out to bill doherty
who'd been a long time friend and
collaborator with him just say you know
bill what do you think about this idea
the the simple version of it is that
bill just said okay let me get involved
in this because otherwise this could go
poorly wrong yeah exactly and so it was
one of his most sort of anxiety-inducing
projects and this is a person who's a
master of crafting space or for you know
empathy
but he did it and the event was so
powerful that he had a dozen or so
people on each side
came into the conversation very much
suspicious of each other came away from
it just sort of loving each other across
the divisions yet two individuals who
started a fairly famous friendship from
that um a fellow named
greg smith a small former small town
sheriff construction worker evangelical
christian just voted for trump and kuyar
mustachi
iranian immigrant
leader of local democratic central
committee uh and just voted for hillary
clinton and there was a moment in that
first workshop where greg wanted to ask
kuyar
a question and he approached him and he
said well actually i guess he was
delivering a statement he said i can
tell you he said my problem with islam
in four letters i asked i before he got
to that last letter kuyar uh sort of you
know gently interrupted him he said my
friend i know what you're going to say
he said but my religion has been
hijacked by people who don't share my my
my values he said can't you think of
people in your religion who may have may
have hijacked your religion too and greg
you know stepped back and thought about
it you know people burning crosses on
the lawns of you know black folks in the
name of jesus christ and realize oh yeah
i absolutely can think of people who've
hijacked my religion so at the end of
the gathering greg and couliar stood up
and informed the group that they'd made
a promise to each other they're going to
work together to bring people together
across these divides kuyar was going to
pay a visit to greg's evangelical church
and greg was going to pay a visit to a
service at cuyar's mosque
and so you know this was in one of many
inspiring stories that came out of that
first workshop
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward national ambassador
for the largest grassroots
depolarization organization in the
country braver angels john wood jr this
week on ford
[Music]
it's my pleasure to welcome to ford the
national ambassador for braver angels
john wood jr welcome john andrew it's so
great to be able to see you in person
man this has been a minute coming i'm
really happy about this yeah i've been
far too long i'm super excited too
uh i have to say you look like a
celebrity but i'm not sure which one so
you know
what do you get my friend
oh man okay well i'll tell you okay i'll
tell you uh what i get so particularly
when i had my hair uh sort of faded down
um
[Music]
i got tiger woods and if i had a
baseball cap on people would actually at
airports stand in front of me so if i
had the facial hair shaved yeah fading
down cap on people would come from
behind me and stand in front of me and
look right in my face to be able to tell
themselves that i wasn't tiger woods and
when people found out my last name was
wood then you know it made it even worse
people like you got to be related and
whatnot and
just you know
one of my pet peeves is people putting
an s on the end of my name it happens
about 50 percent of the time even to
this day you know so the tiger woods
association is this but it consists of
more i can see it with a cap on and you
have this a similar athletic physique to
the same build i'll take that as
government um yeah tiger is great um the
other thing i get more recently is
i i don't i can't remember the name of
the character or the actor
uh but the dude from
um oh wow that's a compliment because
he's a very handsome man oh yeah oh well
i i definitely take that one as a
compliment all i need is you're happily
married though bro
but all i need is
true but all i need is a dinner jacket
and a horse and i'm a british accent too
you gotta have that excellent uh helps
but yeah
so i'm a huge fan of braver angels which
is the largest grassroots
depolarization organization in the
country and i think you actually go and
lead these sessions and workshops where
you take people
and you try to make them
less
partisan less in their own ideological
corner
um so tell me about
uh the work that you do like let's say
like what's the number of people in the
gathering
uh like how is it structured right
definitely okay so let me give you the
layout and i do have experience uh
organizing workshops my own primary
function within the organization is sort
of as a general strategist for the
organization broadly speaking and of
course making the public case uh the
media case and so forth for not just the
work that we do with respect to the
methodologies but for the larger
narrative and philosophy of american
politics that we seek for our work to
sort of sync up with right which i think
makes uh it's a really good fit with
forward i mean it's not that's exactly
what i was going to say i mean i think
what we represent in terms of the shift
in the cultural paradigm of politics
lines up very nicely with where you're
coming from um but
to answer your question we have a wide
range of workshops and programs to say
nothing of our live events media cons
and various other things
so i'll give you a sense of kind of the
spectrum of activities we have something
called a depolarization
depolarizing within workshop which is
basically taking a group of folks and it
could be you know a dozen it could be
four dozen or so
uh and putting them
through
outlining guided exercises for them that
allow them to sort of monitor their
internal dialogue learning to sort of
check themselves so they have a thought
about somebody from the other side
immediately jumping to the sort of
assumption that this person is you know
a racist or this person is you know a
dirt bad commie or something and sort of
giving them kind of the mental sort of
architecture to affix a more nuanced
understanding of who the human being is
likely to be on the other side of an
opinion uh so that's about sort of
internal mindfulness if you will with
respect to polarization okay so so let's
say an organization
says i sense that there's something
amiss within my
uh class within my company or whatnot do
they call you guys up
that is awesome okay so that's one is
structured workshops uh continue right
another we have is called skills for
bridging the divide skills for bridging
the divide and this is specifically
about instructing people in rhetorical
and communicative techniques for being
able to have the difficult conversations
right and so you learn the importance of
i statements you know being willing to
lean into your subjectivity as a way of
demonstrating humility so most of us
will say like oh you know it's just the
fact that obama was the best president
for health care or it's like oh you know
it's obvious that trump is the best
president for the economy and you know
theoretically or hypothetically that
either of those things could be true but
when you just put it out there as like
i'm obviously right about this you put
the other person in the defensive so if
you say well you know in my experience
obama's policies i believe i think et
cetera right exactly suddenly you're
inviting people to a conversation also
the importance of paraphrasing being
able to articulate the other person's
point of view in terms that they
themselves would resonate with as an
accurate expression of what they believe
as opposed to just characterizing say
somebody who's pro-life and saying oh
you just don't think women should have a
right to their to their bodies probably
not how that person thinks about them
themselves but if you say something
along the lines of okay uh the life of
the unborn is sacred to you and that's
why this position matters for you then
they at least can say okay i know you
probably don't agree with me but thank
you for you know you're clearly hearing
what i'm saying right so we have things
like that our most famous workshop the
one that sort of started uh
the organization originally something
called a red blue workshop this is
something that is based off of
principles of family therapy it's
essentially marriage counseling for
republicans and and democrats um
designed by professor bill doherty uh
who's co-founder of braver angels of the
university of minnesota very prominent
uh family therapist incredibly uh wise
man so so cool there's like a family
therapist
who had been mediated all of these
relationships because there's a sense
and i've been saying this to folks that
democrats are like the mom party and
republicans like the dad parties so it
takes a family therapist to try and
right men defense but uh yeah so so how
did that workshop get started i think
you're right about that um well the way
that got started is the origin story of
the organization itself and what year is
this this is 2016 a month after the uh
after the election so
yeah that was the time for a lot of
people like i mean for me right after
trump won i was like what am i going to
do it's like i'm going to prepare to run
for president so yeah
no no exactly exactly no look we we all
one way
or the other we saw what was going on in
america people like you people like you
know me and other folks and said okay
you know time for reasonable people to
try and get involved so the founders of
the organization david blankenhorn uh
formerly president of the institute for
american values uh bill doherty who i
just mentioned and also my colleague and
friend david lapp a scholar
and activist in south lebanon michigan
well david and david had a conversation
after the election comparing how people
were reacting in their own parts of the
country blankenhorn is from mississippi
originally but he lives here in new york
and uh was just basically saying people
here are distraught people here are you
know are are losing it whereas david
lapp in in ohio he said well the time
you know place i'm at he said people are
over the moon most people just can't
couldn't be happier you know i can't
believe how how great this is and so
they asked themselves the question they
said you know people are bitterly
divided is it possible that that
americans can still find common ground
and connect you know maybe we should run
an experiment and find out and so they
have this idea to go to a town uh to a
place in ohio south lebanon ohio a
community that had literally just voted
50 50 for trump and clinton
and they decided to put together uh sort
of a conversation over the course of you
know a day or two bring people together
and see if they could sort of hear each
other out and understand why they came
away voting the way that they did and uh
the problem is is that david and david
are not um you know uh program designers
scholars and intellectuals and so forth
uh and so david david just figured
they'd throw a bunch of people into a
room together and see what happened talk
right but you know david blankenhorn was
smart enough to reach out to bill
doherty who'd been a long time friend
and collaborator with him just say you
know bill what do you think about this
idea and bill said jesus christ this is
going to be a disaster you know you got
to take people who have just come
through sort of a
universally traumatic you know sort of
experience and throw them in a room
together this has to have some structure
and some design
and you know the the simple version of
it is that bill just said okay let me
get involved in this because otherwise
this could go poorly wrong yeah exactly
and so you know
it was one of his most sort of
anxiety-inducing projects and this is a
person who's a master of crafting space
or for you know empathy um
and dialogue but he did it and the event
was so powerful that yet a dozen or so
people on each side um came into the
conversation very much suspicious of
each other came away from it just sort
of loving each other across the
divisions realizing they had deep common
interest deep common commitments to
their community yet two individuals who
started a fairly famous friendship from
that um a fellow named
greg smith a small former small town
sheriff construction worker evangelical
christian just voted for trump and
kudiar mustafi uh iranian immigrant uh
leader of local democratic central
committee uh and just voted for hillary
clinton and there was a moment in that
first workshop but i wasn't there but
this is in the lore you know of of
braver angels
where greg wanted to ask kuyar
a question and he approached him and he
said well actually i guess he was
delivering a statement he said i can
tell you he said my problem with islam
in four letters i asked i before he got
to that last letter kuyar uh sort of you
know gently interrupted him he said my
friend i know what you're going to say
he said but my religion has been
hijacked by people who don't share my my
my values he said can't you think of
people in your religion who may have may
have hijacked your religion too and greg
you know stepped back and thought about
it you know people burning crosses on
the lawns of you know black folks in the
name of jesus christ and realize well
yeah i absolutely can think of people
who've hijacked my religion so at the
end of the gathering greg and kouya
stood up
and formed the group that they'd made a
promise to each other uh kooyar they're
going to work together to bring people
together across these divides kuyar was
going to pay a visit to greg's
evangelical church and greg was going to
pay a visit to a service at kuyar's
mosque and so you know this was in one
of many inspiring stories that came out
of that first workshop and what happened
after that as i understand it is that
the show basically went on the road
they commissioned a bus david
david and david and bill a small crew
which included my colleague kieran
o'connor who i think you know um
and um
april lawson who's become a huge part of
the organization at the heart of the
organization since then was working as a
journalist for david brooks at the new
york times she embedded on the bus and
basically npr picked up the story and
the word got out as to what this group
of people were doing they went from
philadelphia uh to tennessee i believe
um just up and down you know so at that
time bravery angels was called better
angels was it called better angels
during the bus tour they had didn't have
a name yet i think that it did become
better angels during the bus tour um the
better angels bus tour better angels bus
tour that's right and so they became
sort of first responders for communities
suffering from polarization people would
call them and say hey you know we're
going to need a big
bus exactly
you know we can't uh you know function
in our pta meetings our neighborhood is
telling us tearing itself apart can you
come by and help us but at each stop
they were not just holding the workshops
but training volunteers to be able to do
the workshops themselves after they left
right and so incredible that became the
beginning not just of our you know
larger reputation but of our volunteer
and membership base as well and so all
that happened over the course of the
summer of 2017 before i even got to the
organization or had heard of it uh so
yeah that's that's the origin story of
what at the time was better angels
it's 2022 and you like to personalize
just about everything in your life and
yet you drink the same cup of coffee
every morning even though it's gotten a
little bit stale you don't know where
it's sourced why buy the same old same
old instead get a coffee that you know
you're going to love because it's made
for you take the coffee quiz to get
started
trade coffee will source from america's
best independent roasters ethically so
it'll taste great and you'll feel great
about it they guarantee you'll love your
first bank or they will replace it for
free trade has been featured by the new
york times wired gq and has delivered
over five million bags of coffee why not
to you
for our listeners right now trade coffee
is offering a total of twenty dollars
off your first three bags when you go to
drink trade.com yang to get started take
their quiz at drinktrade.com yang and
start your journey to your perfect cup
that's drinktrade.com
yang for 20 off your first three bags
[Music]
so was this during the time that you
were running for congress
is that right no no i actually had run
for congress in 2014. yeah so in 2014
you're so young then man cause you're
young now yeah i was really young then
um yeah
2014. yeah man i um i was the youngest
active nominee for congress in the state
of california i ran against maxine
waters uh and that i think you're 21 is
that right
a little older than that um but i would
have been 26
i think i was 27 on election day yeah
but i started campaigning when i was
about 26 or so um
early in 2013. nobody knew me nobody
knew a damn thing about me you know i
had zero reputation zero resume you know
but i was somebody who so that's a very
bold move to run for i know you can't in
your mid lane
yeah i can't relate to boldness like
that
wait your turn young john
um so
yeah uh what pushed you in that
direction and i know you have something
of like uh i want to say
um like music in your family you're
apparently a very talented uh performer
yourself um and i think that one of the
there's like this strange overlap
between
certain forms of performance
let's call it
actor musician comedian like just
standing in front of a stage and
trying to
create an experience for a group of
people right and then politician
uh so was there like a performance arc
for you when you were young because it's
highly unusual obviously to run for
congress in your mid to late 20s you
know you're the only person who's ever
interviewed me who immediately made that
connection um
yeah so i grew up in a musical
family and the cultural sort of
connection of my family that was made
possible through music had everything to
do with sort of what served as the
backdrop for my candidacy so when i was
running for congress i you know people
would ask me and this was in l.a this
was in los angeles right yeah yeah which
is where you grew up as well that's
correct yeah i grew up in los angeles
and you know whether i was speaking to a
democratic leaning
black church in south central los
angeles or to uh you know white tea
party club in south bay la county people
would ask me they'd say well the age of
26 you know what on earth makes you
qualified to represent a district as
diverse and complex as the california
43rd and i would tell people well i come
from an interesting family background my
mother is a liberal black democrat from
inner city los angeles my father is a
conservative white republican from
tennessee i grew up explaining my mother
to my father my father and my mother and
that's why i can represent all of you
and so you know that always serve for a
laugh and to sort of contextualize my my
message you lived braver angels
[Laughter]
that's why you're the national
ambassador today sorry continue well uh
but uh my parents met through music uh
really uh my father's a jazz pianist uh
my mother's uh rmb singer she danced on
soul train uh you know back in the late
70s early 80s uh my grandfather they met
my grandfather's recording studio my dad
was uh running it as an engineer but my
grandfather owned the biggest
independent record label in america in
the late 50s and still president of in
the early 60s dot records which had 36
million sellers was pat boone's record
label along with lawrence welk and billy
vaughn dell vikings gail storm folks
like that and before that
grandpa started the first radio show in
america sponsored by a mail-order record
shop he owned of the same name uh that
broadcast to broadcast rhythm and blues
and gospel music basically black music
to a national audience so grandpa was a
white man uh but he had a deep love for
black culture and black black music and
so that signal traveled clear across the
south it launched the careers of mahalia
jackson arthur alexander fats domino um
who loved my grandfather very much
solomon burke did also
bob marley recorded his uh early hits at
a recording studio called randy's on a
clear night the signal would travel from
wlac in nashville all the way into
jamaica and the islands and so uh it was
heard there too and so marley recorded
some of his early hits in a studio named
after the radio show and indirectly
after my grandfather
so i grew up as a singer as a trumpet
player you know
even as something of a rapper and the
truth is i never made a career out of it
but i was surrounded by professional
musicians and artists on my mother's
side one of my uncles is mac 10 of the
west side connection which was ice
cube's group after he left nwa and so
forth got you know artists in every
direction
but as a jazz player you know the focus
is on improvisation
and i always had a process uh you know i
was playing on bandstands at the age of
12 and what not my dad and his band and
my little brother um and i always had a
process where you know when my solo was
coming up i would sort of hear the
changes uh you know in the in the music
feel the chords the piano you know
rhythm of the bass and so forth i would
sort of imagine my solo inside of myself
you know before i played it and i would
sort of imagine it and feel how it was
going to make the people the audience
feel and then i would get up and i would
just play what was on the inside
people frequently ask me they say you
know man how long does it take you to
write a speech
i
you know i was able to run that campaign
for congress in part just because i was
a better speaker than anybody else
better on a stage
and my answer to that question is that i
never write speeches you know um
i just if you write a speech this is a
tip for anyone out there let's say you
have a speech to give yeah here's a
list of things not to do
so
the worst speech you can give
is a speech that you've written ahead of
time that you deliver word for word
right it's very very hard for that to be
a good speech yeah so to your point if
you haven't prepared something obviously
you get rid of that as a pitfall
well
yes but but your your point is relevant
because you know i do think that people
who write good speeches have an outline
they have an essential structure but
ultimately you know they're able to
preserve some spontaneity in the
delivery they feel alive they feel
actually like they're speaking to you as
opposed to
uh reciting i mean think of if you're
going on a date you know you're taking
you're taking someone out you're trying
to establish uh a connection right i
mean you might have something of sort of
a game plan going to it i mean i never
did
well me neither actually but you know
but the point being that you know if
you're like reading from a script you've
got some obvious sort of formula and so
forth there's not gonna be any
connection there because you're not
feeling anything you're leaning on this
is something i really struggled with on
the presidential man because like you
know you'd hear these stump speeches
over and over again from these
candidates they weren't quite word for
word but they were close and they were
just such
performances and not even great
performances a lot of the time you know
what i mean right right um all right so
continue i can imagine 26 year old you
holding your own just because you were a
better speaker
like had more presence seem more
composed better thought out
and i deeply studied i deeply studied
you know not just
issues in politics but philosophy
religion history and it's funny because
i was a [ __ ] student andrew to tell you
the truth i actually almost dropped out
of high school another thing that people
assume about me because i i speak at
universities across the country i work
with you know sort of elite academics
and you know psychology and political
science and journalists
get to hang out with folks like you
people tend to think that i must be some
ivy league guy and i've got a little bit
of that
in my family but man i to this day i
don't have a college degree you know uh
which tends to shock people and uh like
i said i mean i
you know i think my gpa graduating high
school is like 1.8 i feel like
technically so what were you doing
instead because clearly you were doing
something was it music was it sports was
it girls
hanging out like
i wish it was girls it was not you know
no i i wanted it to be girls at the time
i was studying i was reading i was just
studying and reading the things that i
wanted to study and read you were
actually like genuinely intellectually
inquisitive and you're like oh this
assigned stuff passed and then you just
went off and read something else yeah i
mean you know and i'm not necessarily
advising that for people who've got you
know students and you know kids at home
where they you know i mean i'm not
saying that good grades are important
and so forth but you know it really was
exceedingly difficult for me
uh to sort of fit into the regimentation
of you know the school environment and
yet i loved studying i buried myself in
books constantly
and would just look at my assigned
homework and be like yeah and would just
keep reading you know whatever it was
yeah whatever it was david copperfield
charles dickens lord of the rings but i
would write too i mean i was constantly
writing stories i would write essays for
myself
sometimes
now part of the reason i was like that
was because my parents did divorce when
i was fairly young and living in my
father's house was like was he raised us
in a time capsule
it's a whole other subject but my dad
has deep sort of you know
antipathy towards a lot of modern
technology and modern popular culture
and so i grew up sort of only being able
at least in my dad's house to watch like
you know old movies i grew up on on you
know music from the 50s and 60s you do
have this
films cary energy you're like a classic
and then the jazz musician and the
steeped in
cary grant films it sounds like there's
there's yeah there's there's a reason
for that the rat pack and so on and so
forth yes because i um yeah i wasn't
allowed to play video games at least in
my dad's house
um my aunt this is terrible story but my
aunt got us got me a mac an imac you
know when it you know first came out i
think it's in seventh grade or something
my dad took it so uh and sold it and
bought its electric three typewriter for
me instead
and so you know but
all of that
did sort of force me to be deeply
acquainted
with certain subjects and parts of
america's cultural and social sort of
history and past which ironically made
it
gave me a clear pathway towards sort of
understanding many older americans
yeah i can see that i guess
you'd be able to click with them so
and i guess it influenced my larger
presentation as well perhaps so you're a
poor high school student and then you
try out college and it's also not a fit
you know i think i probably spent like
uh the better part of like seven uh
inconsistent years trying to get through
community college and never got never i
think i'm probably like six credits away
from a degree but if i got it from like
my associates but if i got it now it
would mess up my whole story you know
yeah i know it's it's not it wouldn't be
very productive it wouldn't be worth it
at this point
um so
what then so you're an indifferent
community college student
um how do you go from your early 20s to
running for congress like what does that
time look like yeah so okay yeah i'll
i'll speed through it but i um
i i worked for barack obama's campaign
in 2008 i'll tell you i was an activist
in high school i gave my first uh public
speech
uh opposing the iraq war at the culver
city city council
meeting yeah at the culver city city
council meeting where the city council
ultimately approved a resolution in
opposition
to the war
and but when george w bush was
re-elected in 2004
i grew up very much considering myself
to be uh sort of a liberal uh uh
democrat and um when he was reelected i
just thought okay
system doesn't work all my hard work was
for nothing
um i was jaded at the age of 17. i was
five days interesting i was five days
too young to vote uh birthday is
november 9th
and uh so without ever having been able
to vote i wiped my hands of politics and
i said i'm done because you know
privileged suburban like you know
millennial kid you know thinking like
he'd suffered too much to
you know continue the fight and so you
know and i might have stayed done if it
weren't for the fact that um my
progressive aunt called me my father's
sister
um my father is you know at this point
very pretty conservative his sister is
very left-leaning my mother's more
liberal her brother is very conservative
so you know
in all directions and she told me she
said there's this young guy she said
he's a new he's the senator of from
illinois she said this was actually
2004. she said he just spoke at the
democratic convention she said he's
amazing i think he could be our next
next uh our first black president and
she was like have you seen him i was
like uh no who are you talking about she
was like his name is funny you don't
know how to pronounce she said i think
it's it's
brock barack obama
and when she said i was like morocco i
was like how are you going to get to be
president of the name like barack o you
know
but when i checked him out uh i sort of
you know heard his story his his
families you know his white mother from
kansas father from kenya sort of i can
see why this would key well and his just
his deep emphasis on sort of humanizing
the fuller spectrum of identities in
american life and i was i was taken with
that i was like sure you know this guy
is really speaking like to the heart of
you know what i what i believe and so i
threw myself into obama's campaign and
just as sort of a foot soldier you know
canvasser and just talking people's ears
off
about about hope and change after he was
elected i sort of committed to myself
that in whatever way i could i wanted to
advance
this cultural movement which for me was
about building towards a post-partisan
post-racial america i was original
of the obama await campaign yes exactly
i was i was you know sick of the hate i
was sick of the narrow mindedness i was
sick of people's inability to listen to
each other not just in america broadly
speaking but even in my own family
because i had grown up in the sort of
intersection of a lot of the cultural
divisions that were you know becoming
more and more visible across the the
country in many respects and so i
a lot of things happened simultaneously
i had made it a point to start studying
conservatism
and paying much deeper attention to what
republicans were talking about than i
had before in an effort to understand
conservative source to be able to bring
them into this this fold at the same
time
i met a woman from a traditional black
baptist background in inner city l.a uh
married her experienced something of a
religious conversion
i've been very sort of anti-organized
religion but
after sort of a series of experiences
reading bible from cover to cover i came
away with my own interpretation of it
that made it sort of deeply resonant
and we moved to colorado springs because
she joined the army we joined a
messianic synagogue which i don't know
if you're familiar with messianic
judaism but it's essentially
judaism that
takes onboard the idea that you know
jesus christ is messiah but preserves of
the culture and ceremony and a lot of
larger theological sort of
interpretations my wife was very was
very enmeshed in that uh for a time but
suffice it to say
that suddenly you know i was in a
context where all my friends are
soldiers and religious people you know
the institution community institutions
of both the military and faith-based
communities were there i was studying
economics in a way i never had before
and want to be impressed by a lot of the
arguments red wealth of nations adam
smith cover to cover atlas shrugged iron
rand and so forth started studying and
this was another key african-american
history from a more conservative vantage
point and developed some skepticism with
respect to the impact of the welfare
state as it has been constituted at
least you know on the interest in the
community cohesion of black and inner
city communities and also came away with
a point of view that recognized the fact
that the greatest political advancement
in terms of civil rights of african
americans in this country had taken
place within the
within the 35-year period of american
life where you actually had bipartisan
representation of the black community
right you actually had black republicans
and democrats in significant numbers
from the new deal era to the to the end
of the civil rights movement
i look i did not like the way they were
talking on fox news i didn't like the
tone of like sean hannity's like you
know rhetoric and i did i thought
there's so much that was divisive and
toxic on on both sides and you know i
didn't think of myself as falling in
love with the republican party but i
suddenly thought of myself as really
seeing a lot of deep value in many
conservative ideas and i thought to
myself
you know what
and i wasn't too impressed with kind of
the obama administration's economic
performance but i still loved obama and
i still loved his original message and i
thought you know what
maybe if i were to take on board you
know sort of
an identification with the republican
party
going to the fact that i agree with a
lot of these ideas and sentiments but
still let people know that i'm still
coming from the same place as somebody
who
not only wants to build these bridges
but who has a deep relationship to the
black experience the inner city
experience the multicultural experience
and who who wants to elevate the
positive values of those spaces as well
maybe i could be a bridge for each side
to relate to and empathize with the
other black and white left and right and
so then was just a question of how can i
go about doing that and i thought
what the hell i'll run for congress i'm
not likely to win but you know i'm
confident in my abilities and i think
that i can make an impact on how people
think and who knows what that might lead
to
and so just so happened when we moved
back to los angeles that that put us in
maxine waters district
uh which meant that i was running
against somebody who was formidable to
say the least in terms of her political
machine but um
[Music]
it was an opportunity that i took and it
set the stage for everything that
followed
[Music]
so after that race uh there's like a
multi-year period before
brave angels even forms
but but it sounds like somehow you're
still activated in trying to
bring people together
uh which brought you to
uh braver angel several years later
right yeah that's right so the way that
worked was in the aftermath of the 2014
election um
you know and so obviously i lost but
although it's a low bar i did better
than any democrat or republican had ever
done
uh before me or after me for that matter
i still have done better running against
maxine waters than anybody else has ever
challenged her and i raised all of 10
000 in that race others have raised
millions and so forth
um but i was elected i was very popular
within the gop in la and i would bet man
you're like a dream well you know as a
matter of fact national review wrote an
article about me called john woods
california dream uh which was sort of my
first introduction to any you know bit
of
national recognition um
and uh but i tried to bring a sort of a
you know a fraternal
spirit uh to to political culture within
the institutional republican party as it
existed in california and los angeles i
wanted to move towards a place to where
we could compete with democrats we would
be competitive but we're also looking
for opportunities to engage with them in
public conversations to be able to
explore issues together and see if we
could maintain competitive fervor while
still strengthening relationships
between communities what wound up
happening was that i
i had people who wanted to run me out of
town from within the party on the basis
of the fact that i was too friendly with
the wrong republicans
because at that time there was a deep
and bitter and this this was you know
across much of the party across the
country but certainly in la and
california uh there's a deep and bitter
sort of you know civil war between the
more sort of establishment and kind of
traditional conservative crowd on the
one hand and the young multicultural uh
ron paul wing libertarian uh crowd on
the other hand
uh and
i stepped into this race to you know
help lead the la county party sort of
having been drafted by the more
establishment side but not really
knowing how deep the feud was and so i
ran a campaign that was about bringing
those sides together and it worked for
me as a candidate for that party office
but afterwards was sort of sort of made
clear to me that like yo that's not
going to work like as a way of doing
business here you know and so
i you know what one uh aside but this is
something i'm
very certain of
there are
really really talented
uh principled congressional candidates
who lose
uh that we don't hear enough from
like i i've spoken now i endorsed a
couple dozen at least
uh in 2020 most all of whom lost because
i was endorsing folks who were kind of
uh you know outsiders or um you know
running in districts that were very
unfavorable to them
um you're endorsing people like me i
think yeah yeah
and
some of them like virtually all of them
i thought were really really impressive
humans and i'm going to suggest even
that if you decide to run
a race that you're likely to lose
um that takes like a different type of
uh fortitude and
uh motivation it's like this is not a
careerist move this is like a hey i'm
going to do it uh because it's the right
thing it does if you're if you're
serious there are people who run as
perennial candidates who just sort of
you know get addicted to it as
you know they're one way into some
semblance of the spotlight but for
people who really commit to making an
impact knowing they're going to lose it
takes believing in something beyond your
own advantage and and they you know i
mean they think that if everything
breaks right they're going to win
but it's unlikely most of them do lose
um so i have a friend who is an investor
type and he says he constantly tries to
find these people and have them work in
non-profits that he's on the board of
because they're very talented
in that regard one person whose story
this reminds me of a little bit is
crystal ball
who now people you know may or may not
remember but she was a young
congressional candidate in a red
district yeah i think it was virginia
and lost and then wound up on msnbc
briefly and then you know was uh like uh
cast out for being too
independent-minded or something like
that and now she's
not no no she's um blazing an incredible
trail
i was inspired by her example um so oh
crystal be uh pumped to hear that i'm
sure yeah um i've never met her but that
yeah but they're i mean you should
should visit with them they're great
people her and sagar
i think are some of the you know best
uh voices on current events today um
but that there's it's not just you and
crystal though i mean i spoke to so many
people who resemble this that i thought
like wow this person
uh is incredible and they could be you
know running more than frankly like you
know representing a congressional
district like i'd put this person
uh in in charge of all sorts of stuff
but our system doesn't really allow
for a path forward for a lot of those
people because let's say that you're
in the minority party in a district uh
let's say you run for congress and lose
and then uh what's the next step it's
like well
you know like you can't just keep
running for congress over and over and
losing and if you're in that community
and your party's not in power
then you know there's not much of an
opportunity for you so a lot of times
you like just leave politics all
together i'm guessing yeah right yeah no
that that
that tends to be the way of it you have
good people who who
step in for a moment um they are people
who are probably very competent in their
own areas of life their own professions
and so forth very often so yes and and
and very often people who therefore
or at least i would say not unrelated to
that also buy in a little bit less to
the tribal sort of narratives around
which the parties struggle probably also
true congeal and and derive a lot of
their sort of moral authority and what
happens is people experience the
toxicity they experience the ugliness
you know they find themselves getting
pushed into places there's a lot of
excellent people who see this stuff too
and are like hard pass i'm not going to
put myself through that well that's what
it is it's either hard pass and they
don't run or they do run and they get a
taste of how nasty it is how little
they're actually in a position to do
and then it's like why continue like
this you know and these are some of the
people who you really do in and i wish
you were actually in
positions of authority right so you know
what i tried to do was so i left kind of
i'm still a registered republican to
this day um and and happy to be so you
know if you want we can talk about the
larger sort of space there but
i left uh active sort of you know employ
with with the party um
and um
launched uh sought to launch digital
media network uh
that was
meant to lift up voices
uh not left or right but left and right
voices who would disagree with each
other
politics
but who agreed on how we ought to treat
each other in politics yeah yeah okay so
the question of what it is called i
can't give you the answer to that
question because of how the project
ultimately ended it was
sort of stepped on by a multi-billion
dollar you know corporation that didn't
like the fact that the
name of our
network was somewhat close to theirs
even though we were dealing with news
and information and they were dealing
with you know baseball caps and
basketball jerseys and other things and
so
i um
you know wound up sort of
feeling like i was at a low point i mean
i'd run for congress i had you know
served as vice chair of the la county
republican party which came with a fair
amount of you know accolades and some
degree prestige but was actually
volunteer position right i didn't get
paid for any of that uh i was juggling
multiple part-time jobs with first
family support first one little kid and
then two you know uh living uh where we
still live but living in a you know
little apartment in south los angeles
and um you know wife very much sort of
like hey john at a certain point you
know i know you have this dream of you
know kind of
changing
changing the political discourse and
culture of america reaching the
conscience of
american democracy but at a certain
point you're gonna have to consider just
getting a regular nine to five which i
do about as well with regular nine to
fives as i did in you know high school
exactly
uh but you know it was around so you
know it's like a year of my life into
getting this media network going only to
have it kind of snuffed out just as it
was starting to get some traction but
then a friend of mine pointed out to me
the existence of an organization called
better angels now the thing is is that
my concept for a media network was
always meant to jump off the screen the
idea was to be able to build up a
cross-partisan cross-cultural following
right that
which by the way just a brief thing is
kind of what i'm doing now with forward
like you know this podcast and
everything else
where all politics is tribal and there's
this massive tribe that's not spoken two
or four right and so you were uh
marching at that problem a number of
years ago
uh so continue yes yes i mean you know
at the time um
you know yeah so i had this idea i had
taken some inspiration
from uh the reuben report and his
success i'm dave rubin at that time uh
you know he's not quite this way now and
i like dave and i consider dave a friend
i've gotten to know him a little bit
um but in those years dave was really
sort of brokering kind of you know
heterodox conversations from across the
spectrum in ways that really seem to be
bringing the best out of people who you
knew politically speaking were worlds
apart and so there were some there were
some examples of this in different
spaces but i just thought that there was
a way to sort of
model that culture and then scale it out
in a manner that would allow it to
translate to direct sort of social
mobilization on the ground around not
just sort of like political projects but
possibly community development sort of
sort of activities and various other
various other fronts when people come
together in a creative and
entrepreneurial spirit there's no limit
to what they can do to solve real world
problems
and so i had this idea and i looked at
better angels and they were already
having the sorts of relationship
building conversations and events in
local communities that i had wanted a
thought a media network structure could
kind of build
exactly
but you know their website was kind of
like you know text heavy and pixelated
they had a facebook page that sort of
was
abandoned a youtube channel with a
couple of nice clips but nothing else
going on and so i just thought to myself
i thought well maybe there's room for my
media network idea within this
organization it was a long shot but i
drove down to san diego sat in on a
workshop with my pal luke phillips who i
think you you may also know my buddy
looks like pete bootage and is now a
long-standing uh braver angels volunteer
scholar historian young guy and um
presented my media network idea to david
blankenhorn who was at that workshop and
so was bill dougherty he ran the
workshop peter yarrow peter paul and
mary was there too playing the guitar
and then saying it
and
david was thrilled with the idea
ultimately i was hired to build out the
media network for for better angels
still wound up being faced with a lot of
the limitations i had before you know we
didn't really have any money for it i
also wasn't really my competence i had
the vision but i didn't really have you
know much experience of any kind of
production media but i was brought on
board to build out the media network
structure david committed to me from the
very beginning he wanted better angels
to be a platform for me as a public
intellectual and a public voice as a
writer and so forth on issues of race
and polarization and i very quickly just
became sort of a general kind of
spokesperson and then national
ambassador as well as a larger sort of
strategist because i had community
organizing experience and various other
things i i very quickly became a
spokesperson and strategist for the
organization broadly speaking
and um you know and so that was march of
2018
and at which point you know john would
you be four years yep the history's
converged and so that's where the that's
where the stories meet and um you know
what eventually
leads me here to being with you
[Music]
so uh why the name change uh from better
angels to
bravery angels was there like a process
behind that well yeah so it was a couple
of things i like bravery angels by the
way i don't you know well good i'm glad
it actually was my uh my my name child
um
and uh there are two things that
happened one was
once again
uh trademark
dispute someone didn't like better
angels yeah no somebody somebody with
more money than we had was a bit upset
about that and things were ultimately
resolved amicably so you know it's it's
okay but
um we had to step away from the original
name and you know the name better angels
is uh taken from abraham lincoln
quotation you know abraham lincoln yeah
i thought this was from yeah well yeah
that's absolutely right it was uh you
know
referenced um you know touching the
better angels of our nature
in his first inaugural address on the
eve of the civil war right trying to
sort of stave off the the apocalypse
that was to was to come
so better angels that's where the name
original name came from i advocated for
a shift to braver angels for two reasons
one of them practical uh being the fact
that i thought a similar sounding name
would allow us to preserve as much brand
recognition as we could right uh they're
close right i'd assume they're the same
exactly so you know on that front it
seemed like a sound choice but also
you know
there is uh something of uh you don't
prefer what's that courageous angels now
i'm kidding
well maybe the trademark is available
probably you know
um but the other but the more
substantive um reason was you know there
is a cottage industry of
um
you know philanthrop well of of
nonprofit organizations and foundations
committed to depolarization and bridge
building work this field is now in the
last few years expanded rapidly other
players everyone's redemption
right and so it's now becoming more sort
of firmly um
formed and it's maturing but
you but you've had sort of a cottage you
know uh sector for a while doing this
kind of work within which you know the
value and virtue of empathy has always
been
foundational and this is the thing that
uh is destroying us in my opinion is
that
if someone's your
ideological enemy
they're now
not just worthless as a human being
they're actually
not human or dehumanized and so
whatever vitriol you directed them is
somehow now justified right like that
that's the core problem
yeah well it is it is and there's so
much more we can say about that but the
reason and owing to that fact you know
in this sort of sector as it had existed
you know there is naturally a deep sort
of emphasis on the value of empathy in
being sort of the spirit that guides
bridge building work and of course
because you know in order to really
develop a deep relationship of trust
with you
if especially if we are tribal you know
opposites it's gonna be important for me
to be able to demonstrate the fact that
i can kind of you know put myself in
your shoes to sort of see things as you
see things and demonstrate the fact that
i you know have some understanding of
who you are what's important to you and
that i care enough to have that
understanding and demonstrate it so the
emphasis on empathy is is needed but
it it had long been evident to me
that to really
pursue this work into sort of the heat
of america's tribal and political
conflicts which is where it needs to go
it takes more than just being empathetic
you really do need courage you really do
need bravery increasingly unfortunately
well and and for for two uh two
immediate reasons one the most obvious
one is that you try and reach out to
people who have you know
uh
have been
culturally kind of like you know pitted
against you
there's gonna be oftentimes a level of
distrust uh towards you and maybe even a
tendency towards being a little bit mean
towards you maybe just on the basis just
maybe just on the basis of the fact that
you're from the other party but
people in your own party your own
comrades and compatriots
will oftentimes look at you with some
degree of suspicion
and maybe even you know a sense that
you've sold out you know on the basis of
the fact that you do choose to empathize
with people who think differently
because people on each side are you know
to whatever degree find themselves
committed to the notion that look i
can't i i can't
you know
with those people yeah i can't socialize
with with these people i can't keep
company with them because if i do i'm
entertaining fascists if i do i'm
entertaining people who hate america
right and if you're doing that and you
say you agree with me but you're friends
with them that i've got a little bit of
suspicion towards you too so bravery
wound up being a necessary point of
emphasis and i think that it helped to
to fortify the message of braver angels
in a way that has been more empowering
for people who have come into our ranks
and has had influences on the larger
space as well i agree and i like it and
i want to
affirm
that one of the most noxious beliefs
nowadays is that if i sit with you
then somehow i'm vouching for everything
you believe in about everything under
the sun and if there's one other
statement that's like oh you you know
hung out with that person and thus you
you blessed everything about them and if
they don't you know like the entire
thing is like yeah well you know i talk
to people in real life all the time and
like i'm you know
i don't agree with everything that
um that that they say uh and there's a
word that bugs me
and it's funny now because i i i you
know i'm something of a public figure
and i i i like have um uh a platform but
this term platforming it's like oh you
platformed this person right you've like
given them
uh
elevation giving them legitimacy
legitimacy it's like you bless this
person who is intrinsically illegitimate
and you're just like you know
like like when did
sitting with someone somehow
like have this kind of weight to it
where like you're like oh can't talk to
that person and there's so many people
now who uh suffer and struggle with this
where there's like oh you know it's like
i i can't be seen with this person like
it's really
uh it's worse than counterproductive
there are two things i mean there are
multiple things but they're they're
they're two things that i'll mention
that are intersecting i think it's like
how the heck are you gonna bring people
together if you're like not allowed to
you know have a conversation well that's
the thing that's fine for many folks
there's a limit to the value of bringing
people together right and so there are
two things that i see sort of
intersecting here that are that are most
salient you know one is the fact that
we've come to a point now in american
life where as opposed to times past
where republicans and democrats you know
different parties but there's very
little like deep-seated social animosity
between the parties you know um yeah i
mean now back in the 50s and 60s you
know
there were polls taken i think at least
in the 60s asking the question if your
child married a republican or a democrat
would you care and it's like five
percent of americans cared people were
you know but if they were catholic right
i'm not sure what the exact figure is
but is well upwards of 50 yeah that was
52. yeah yeah yeah i think it's upwards
of 50
um now nobody cares what religion you
are it's a question of what you know
what your political party well politics
is the new religion well yes and
unfortunately media tribes when i was
sitting with arthur brooks he said that
like media tribes are the new uh many
religions well so the difference is
you're forming a new mini religion well
you know civic religion is a phrase that
has some history to it you might be i
don't you maybe you know eric lou uh
yeah yeah so there's some eric talks
about
but
so the differences between us have
extended to being beyond the pale for
people in a way to where you know it's
not just that we have a good faith
disagreement about something that's
important but we have a you know i can
infer at least that we have a moral
disagreement on things that are
characterologically determinative of
your value as a human being in some
respects right and so that makes us not
want to interact but you couple that
with the fact that we live in an
attention economy within which we are
competing for space to be heard we have
more opportunities and more platforms to
be heard than ever but the competition
over that i think is probably fiercer
than it has ever been and so i think
people have a sense of okay if you have
a platform holy [ __ ] we all want a
platform especially a platform that
people actually come to
and so if you have a platform you have
ethical responsibility you've got to use
that resource you know wisely you know
if you put give that resource to
somebody who's going to use it to
advance systemic racism just for for
example you know um
then you are you know you are investing
in
that uh anti-human project you're
investing in that project of hate uh and
so you know um the intensity of sort of
the competition within the kind of you
know information and you know attention
economy
meets this moral paranoia and i don't
say moral paranoia to be dismissive of
it because you know look i i
i get it i mean people have deeply felt
reasons for not wanting to elevate you
know milo yiannopoulos or whoever you
know whatever it is you're you're
talking about well i guess we've all
forgotten about milo at this point um
that's a fine example i got it oh yeah
right um
but it yes it's created this context in
which we need to now make the case
for why it is utterly imperative not
just for the survival of democracy but
also for the advancement to put in the
racial justice context of a larger uh
project um of of equity and equality and
social justice in american life to be
able to engage our neighbors yes right
in constructive discourse we have to
make that case a new now in 2022. yeah
that that's the case i'm making as well
man
[Music]
i have i think a lot of people know this
about me but like i i think that we need
to make big changes yeah uh i don't
think the status quo is working um but i
also don't think that our current
structures are actually
conducive to major changes uh and so
you have to try and shift those
structures in order to shift those
structures you need to build a coalition
of people that might not agree on a lot
of stuff but can agree that
this situation is not working that we're
getting more and more polarized we're
turning on each other in various ways we
are
in danger in my view of falling into
widespread political violence uh
over the next number of
months
let's say
um so i i i mean i see it too how these
things have interlinked in a way but i i
think that they're
again corrosive uh and um keeping us
from solving the real problems like
there's this
multi-billion dollar set of incentives
to uh inflame and anger us in our own
kind of echo chambers
uh and then there's you
uh and me
and some other people
who we wish we had billions of dollars
that we could you know but put to work
in in various ways um so bravery angels
i know is uh growing um you're saying
that the space itself is getting more
resources and attention which is wholly
appropriate
um what is
upcoming for you first you share my
concern level about what what may be
around the corner for
us in this country and second what are
you working on what are you excited
about with braver angels and also if
someone
is inclined to
participate in or help what i think is a
tremendous organization
how can they do so yeah absolutely and
thank you for those questions um first
of all yes i mean i i do share your
assessment honestly andrew i mean look
we've already seen yeah political
violence sure you know you know january
6 but also the summer of 2020 and so
forth you know
and also after january 6th uh there were
dozens of republicans who were ready to
vote to
impeach trump or investigate what
happened or what not they all got death
threats and most all of them back down
yeah yeah so when you talk about
political violence i'm going to suggest
that
that uh constituents threatening
uh their representatives families and
whatnot like should be classified in
that category and it's completely having
an effect and we're not paying enough
attention to the peter myers on the adam
kinzinger's and uh liz cheney's who
tried to buck the trend and said look
like i think this is right because
they you know like they they have had
uh personal threats uh against them in
serious ways it takes serious courage to
take the stands they've taken you know
and if you're a republican you know
listening to us who supports you know
donald trump you might disagree with the
chance they've taken but recognize the
fact that these are i think sincere
folks they are coming from a place of
courage their principle like like how is
it that taking that stand i mean it it
it's clearly
from a place of principle because it's
not serving your interest it's not
serving your dreams politically or
personally no no it's it's it's not i
mean their future in the republican
party in terms of any greater influence
you know is is done at least with
respect to this why we need a third
party man
stands right
um yeah there you go but
the um
but i share your assessment um
so in terms of what's coming up for
braver angels look these are this is a
key year and these next few years
i mean listen man you know
um
we are in a moment in american life
right now
where
you have
widespread distrust of the institutions
generally but of the electoral process
in particular there's actually a way in
which of course it manifests on the left
in terms of you know believing that our
structures are geared towards voter
suppression so forth and there are
definitely good faith arguments to be
had you know over the way in which the
system needs to be reformed but on the
right the belief that you know [ __ ] is
just flat out stolen
fraudulently
this leads to a circumstance in which
people if people both believe that that
is true and also believe that there is
not sufficient
goodwill within our institutions and our
body politic to be able to hear out each
other's concerns and lead towards
intelligent reforms of the system that
may allow us to re-establish trust then
what option will people see for
themselves other than resorting to the
most extreme behavior that they can you
know
tolerate in order to make their voices
heard or otherwise just find ways to
kind of divorce themselves from larger
society which you know uh is
also feeds into the fact that there are
many many
uh men in particular who've been
displaced
uh economically and socially yes it does
uh and so you're you have a lot of dry
tinder that's right that's right because
the the
the contempt is not just for the
electoral project it's for every
institution in major institution in
society yes it's for the presidency it's
for congress it's for the electoral
system it's for the courts but it's also
for the financial system it's for
hollywood and the media in the media
industry um it's for the education
system right believing that our
professors are just there to
indoctrinate our students and so forth
and again you know you go you know you
look on the left and there's a sense
that all of this is just sort of white
supremacist architecture anyway right
and so but with respect to the specific
question of our confidence in the
electoral system
um
all these things are coming to a head
and that's really coming to a head
because we have a we have a date with
that question 2022 midterms but then
presidential election in 2024 where we
are going to vote there is going to be a
shift in power or you know you know
rearranging of power you know following
that and then there's going to be the
question of do we believe that it is
legitimate donald trump is still here
donald trump has not given an inch you
know in terms of what he believes or
says he believes was the case about you
know the 2020 election
and you do have larger forces that are
pushing that narrative forward right
okay so braver angels
in
in upcoming weeks um
but i think it's okay for me to share
this with you here we are
launching
[Music]
an initiative uh you'll see the details
of it roll out this is gonna be in
partnership with a significant uh
national uh partner uh and various
different organizations uh to basically
see braver angels workshops uh across
the country uh we have programming that
is unfolding in congress now working
with the select committee for the modern
day foundation of congress that's right
uh but these programs are meant to be
seated in state houses and local
governments and potentially even school
boards across america
mobilizing our national organizing
infrastructure but joining hands with
various other partners uh to push things
forward and um you know the only reason
i'm not you know saying more about it is
because yeah i got to leave something
for the press and now yeah exactly don't
want to don't want to step in front of
uh our pr very exciting though right
it is and see the
the power of this isn't just in the
context of you know planting workshops
in in local governments people come up
to us and they'll say okay well you know
i can see it being a good thing that you
have city councilmen or state assembly
you know persons uh engaging in a red
blue workshop and they are impactful you
know even for elected officials but
people make the case that there's a
difference between an elected official
between a regular you know you know joe
or jane and the neighborhood whose chief
issue with polarization is their
inability to hang out with each other
versus state legislators who are
institutionalized who have surrounding
structural interests but the power of
this initiative isn't just in terms of
seeding the workshops it's it's also
owing to mobilizing you know a larger
community of americans to engage their
elected officials and engage each other
in an actionable pathway towards
pushing their elected officials to model
the culture that they themselves are
calling for and organizing around as
communities of constituents and so you
don't just have a methodology that's
going to be participated in but you have
the rallying of voters right saying this
is the kind of politics we want to see
this is the kind of change you know we
want to see me manifest and in the
course of doing you know you exercise
people's organizational muscles to work
alongside of each other right
so look i mean we're going to be
starting you know um relatively small
here i mean we're going to be piloting
in in particular areas seeing what we
learn and scaling out
but you know over the course of not just
this year but the few years to come
especially as we get into 2024 the
serious goal here is to be able to
mobilize a significant enough portion of
america and on a percentage basis i
don't think it has to be all that does
not need to be at all
you can fall well short of one percent
of voters and make an amazing impact on
you know the culture and the flow of you
know politics in our society but the
idea is to get to the point at which we
achieve a critical mass that's able to
be impactful building up braver angels
reach and structure and apparatus but
also working with partners from across
the spectrum as well right and i you
know i can't say this clearly enough man
what we do is for folks or you know
social justice activists black lives
matter and trump supporting populists
you know on on the right the question
isn't what you believe politically the
question is are you willing to see the
humanity in your fellow american right
are you willing to acknowledge and treat
that person with dignity if so you got a
seat at our table and you can join us as
a member and potentially a volunteer if
you want to get your hands dirty at
braverangels.org
well
thank you john wood jr for being
a very effective ambassador for a very
very important organization that i love
everyone i've met from braver angels has
been really
uh human
empathetic
patriotic principled and brave
uh and i cannot wait to do everything we
can to support you and your work well i
would be remiss if i didn't give a shout
out to our mutual friend silas kulkarni
uh who's been a tremendous leader within
braver angels and who's really been a
tremendous advocate within our larger
community for the forward party
uh and for the movement that obviously
you've been inspiring americans with for
some time now and uh i'm just grateful
that we've been able to make this
connection and you know look forward
forward party plus braver angels
uh equals maybe democracy survives maybe
we continue to appreciate each other's
common humanity even if we don't agree
on everything and set the paradigm for
democracy that may be better than it's
ever been yeah i mean heck let's let's
not settle for
you know survival uh let's shoot for
flourishing there you go there you go
john thank you so much thank you brother
andrew
appreciate you
[Music]
you